مقابله ضخمه مستديره وعلى طرفها بتلك
الزاويه الرئيس الفرنسي
مهلا مهلا مهلا لنعد
[موسيقى]
وان الصين مستعده لان تدعم اوروبا لتحصل
على استقلال عالمي بدلا من بقائهم يدورون
في الفلك الامريكي هناك تظهر الحكمه
الصينيه وللقصه بقيه امريكا تطلق الرصاص
على نفسها
الطائره الفرنسيه تداعب الاراضي الصينيه
معلنه وصول رسول بايدن وما على الرسول الا
البلاغ الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ورئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه يصلان برسالهما والتي
تفوح منها رائحه التهديد الامريكي التي
يتوعد فيها البيت الابيض الصين لانها اذا
لم تتوقف عن مناوراتها العسكريه
وقبحينيتها عن احتلال تايوان وتتوقف ايضا
عن دعم الدب الروسي في حروبه ضد الغرب فان
بكين ستواجه التحالف الامريكي الاوروبيه
العسكري وسيكون مصيرها اسوا بكثير مما
عندما تذهب امريكا لاي عراق دولي او سياسي
لابد ان تلوح بالعصا الاوروبي ولكني يبدو
ان واشنطن لا تعلم ان الحكيم الصيني سيكسر
العصا الامريكيه دون ان يتحرك من مكانه
بين مصير تعلم جيدا ان ذاك الفتى الفرنسي
يطمح لقياده اوروبا ولم يتكيف مع العباءه
الامريكيهمس لمكون ويقولها عن قرب دعك من
الرساله الامريكيه وهيا لمداعب احلامك
اعطت الصين درسا عن كيفيه الخروج من دائره
الصراع الامريكيه وفوائده وامام الصحافه
العالميه مكون يصدم ابناء العم سام وقالها
على الملا يتعين على اوروبا تقليل
اعتمادها على الولايات المتحده وان تتجنب
الانجرار الى مواجهه الصين بشان تايوان
معلنا بذلك
عن الوقوف خلف امريكا بل ولم يكتفي بذلك
ليحرض اوروبا كلها بعدم دعم الولايات
المتحده في معركه ضد الصين وطالب الدول
الاوروبيه بتقليص الاعتماد على الدولار
الامريكي في معاملات التجاريه وكانه يدعو
القاره العجوز للتحالف من اجل اسقاط الغول
الامريكي ولم يكتفي الرئيس الفرنسي بذلك
ايضا بل هاجم امريكا علنا وحملها مسؤوليه
الازمات الاوروبيه قائلا الخطر الكبير
الذي تواجهه اوروبا اليوم هو انها علقت في
ازمات ليست من شانها فماذا استفدنا واضافه
ماذا يمنعنا من بناء استقلاليتنا
الاستراتيجيه خارج امريكا نزل التصريحات
الرئيس الفرنسي على رؤوس الامريكان
كالصاعقه واصبح لسانه حالهم يقول يا الهي
ماذا يح لقد ارسلناك لتهدد الصين ونستعرض
عضلاتنا امامها فتهددنا وان تقف على
الاراضي الصينيه ماذا حدث يا ماكون كانت
الصدمه شديده على مسؤلي البيت الابيض ولكن
يظل السؤال ما هي كلمه السر التي استغلت
الصين لتقلب الفتى الفرنسيه وقالبوا بها
ايضا حاله امريكا راسا على عقلك الهجمه
الصينيه المرتده كان الرئيس الصيني شي جيم
بينج على علم كامل برساله التهديد
الامريكيه ولكن لم تكن واشنطن تعلم ان
الصين ستوجه لها صفعه قويه وبنفس سلاحها
فبعد ابلاغ مكون ورئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه الرئيس الصيني بفحو الرساله
الامريكيه فوجئوا به يحدثهم عن استقلال
الدول اوروبا الاستراتيجي وان مكان اوروبا
الصحيح هو قياده العالم بعد ان تقلص دورها
كثيرا الحرب العالميه الثانيه وتسليمها
شاره القياده للولايات المتحده واكد لهم
النصين مستعده لان تدعم اوروبا في كافه
المجالات من اجل الحصول على استقلالها من
الوصايه الامريكيه وان تصبح قطبا اساسيا
له دور مؤثر على الساحه الدوليه وان تخدم
اوروبا مصالحها بعيدا عن اوامر واشنطن
ليقبل العرض الصيني وينقلب على واشنطن قبل
حتى ان يغادر الصين وسط صدمه وذهول الجميع
ما عدا الرئيس الصيني الذي كان يعرف ما
دار وراء الكواليس ولكن لماذا قدم شي هذا
العرض وما سر ثقته الكبيره بان ماكرون
سيقبله وينقلب على امريكا بهذه السرعه
ذراع امريكا المؤلم
يعلم جيدا ان مكون يحلم منذ وقت طويل
بالخروج من عباءه الولايات المتحده وان
تتوحد القوى الاوروبيه كلها تحت قيادته
كما لو كان يطمح باستعاده امجاد
ولكن هذه المره سيحاربون الجديد هيمنه
واطمع واشنطن والانانيه الامريكيه التي لا
ترى بعينيها الا مصلحتها فقط حتى وان
اراقت في سبيلها دماء الابرياء لذا فان
عرض الرئيس الصيني على مكون استطاع به
التنين الاسيوي الامساك بامريكا من الذراع
الذي يؤلمها فخروج اوروبا من عباءه واشنطن
يعني فقدان امريكا لاكثر من نصف قوتها
خصوصا القوه الاقتصاديه كما انها ستفقد
جيد المجتمع الدولي لقراراتها العنتريه
التي تعد اوروبا الداعم الرئيسي لها
والوقود الذي يغذي الامريكيه كل هذا دار
بخلد الصين قبل ان تقدم افضل عرض لمكون بل
ولاوروبا كلها وليس بعيدا ان يكون الامر
بدعم من الدب الروسي ليقلب التنين الصيني
الطاوله في وجه الغور الامريكيه ويقتله
بنفس الرصاصه التي اطلقها عليه فياال
خطورتكم يا اصحاب العيون الضيق والمدهش في
الامر ان التنين الصيني استطاع ان يدير
الامور بما يخدم مصالحه فقد انتهت الزياره
بموافقه الرئيس الفرنسي على العرض المغري
رغم الاهانه التي تعرض لها في الصين فما
هي الاهانه التي تعرض لها مكون على يد
الصينيين
الملاكمه السياسيه
من وجود علاقه بين رياضه الملاكمه العنيفه
ومصالح الدول السياسيه ولكن كانت هذه هي
العلاقه الحقيقيه بين فرنسا والولايات
المتحده منذ سنوات عديده فقد كان كلاهما
يوجه لكمات للاخر بينما تقف اوروبا تشاهد
المباراه تنتظر لتعرف من منهما سيسقط اولا
يرى ان امريكا تقود اوروبا معصوبه العينين
وتستنزف ثرواتها وخبرتها من اجل تحقيق
مصالحها هي فقط وان اوروبا لا تستفيد اي
شيء من السير وراء طموحاتي واطماع ابناء
العم سام وحدث في عهد الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب ان طلب ايمانويل
المجتمع الاوروبي على نمط بانشاء منظومه
دفاعا مشترك تقتصر على الدول الاوروبيه
فقط والعمل على الاستقلال الاستراتيجي
للدول القاره الخروج من محيط اوامر واشنطن
وان على اوروبا ان توقف دعمها للقرارات
الامريكيه وان تتعامل بما يخدم مصالحها هي
وليس مصالح امريكا لترد واشنطن اللكمه
بتجاهل الراي الاوروبي تماما لانسحاب
قواتها من افغانستان فقد قامت امريكا بسحب
قواتها من افغانستان بقرار احادي دون ان
تستشير الدول الاوروبيه او حتى تنظر الى
رايها بعد ذلك ولم تكن تلك هي اللكمه
الوحيده التي وجهتها واشنطن لباريس ففي
عام 2016 كانت فرنسا قد ابرمت صفقه تقضيب
ان تبيع لاستراليا مجموعه من الغواصات
البحريه كانت قيمه الصفقه 50 مليار يورو
ولكن قبل ان يتم كل شيء قفزت كل من امريكا
وبريطانيا للاستيلاء على الصفقه لصالحهما
ويمنعان باريس من الحصول على اي ممتعه
وهذا ما لم ينساه الفرنسيون للامريكان كان
هذا جزءا يسيرا من مظاهر وجولات العداء
الفرنسيه الامريكي ولا احد يعلم الى ماذا
سينتهي هذا العداء والان هل ترى ان امريكا
ستخرج من كل تلك المعارك منتصره ام ان
اصحاب العيون الضيقه والدب الروسي سيصنعون
نظاما عالميا جديدا
[موسيقى]